and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review the
amazing spider-man 2 oh my god this is a
great movie I've ever seen in my life
spoiler man spoiler man will we ever let
this song go here's this guy called
Peter Parker
most people know him as spider-man the
one who doesn't cry a lot and he has an
on-again off-again relationship with
Gwen Stacy and she's like 200 my
father's dying request I will totally
stay away from your hot muscles your
incredibly good looks and the fact that
you're a superhero and I will totally
stay away from you despite the fact that
you're a genius hot as hell and we both
have raging teenage hormones
we're already heavy too just talking to
each other aren't we yes but spider-man
runs into not blind Ray Charles and he's
like I'm the stereotypical geek who's
obsessed with you being a superhero
Oh like most comic book fans I look
forward into turning my obsession into
absolute hate for you oh my most comic
book fan Andrew you don't give a shit
sciency becomes electro and what's his
diabolical plan I just want to feel
needed really your motivation is as
blunt and obvious as a Care Bear special
it needs to be aware to make room for a
million more product devices like Harry
Osborn so there's this kid named Harry
Osborn and his father is a wasted chris
cooper cameo and he discovers that he's
also dying from wasted chris cooper
cameo eidest symptoms including one of
too many characters having most of what
makes you interested be sidelined and
appearing in a silly costume for the
last few moments of the movie these
symptoms can kill a movie if Matt check
by your doctor or screenwriter also the
Rhino is in the movie I'm in the movie
and that's all he does so spider-man is
on the verge of figuring out what
actually happened to his dead parents
and the result is totally shocking love
of God great discovery blah blah blah
bad guys want to use his weapon
blah blah blah I may get killed ooh and
I have never seen an action movie or
comic book have quite a big twist like
that except for all that so Harry Osborn
is dying from his disease again
Spiderman's blood in order to cure it
but spider-man is like I can't why not
because it'll kill you I'm gonna die
anyway then for reasons what reasons
you're not reasons to leech is very big
big reason you know my life is on the
line I think you could at least tell me
okay reasons Oh so Harry Osborn teams up
with not blind Ray Charles and Mary is
like you know who I am at you emo Peter
from spider-man 3 yes they figured I
destroy spider-man ones why not have me
do it again
given our motivations I think we are the
most pathetic spider-man villains the
movies I've ever had polluting the Rhino
- I remember movie doctor Gwen Stacy
makes a great big speech about what a
beautiful future is ahead she gets
accepted to Oxford revealing what a
beautiful future lies ahead and her
inspire may agree to live together
showing what a beautiful future lies
ahead surprisingly wait wait out of the
blue a beautiful future does not die
ahead unless a beautiful future means
the back your head being used like a
basketball which I don't think votes
well forgetting at Oxford so spider-man
is really sad that his girlfriend is
dead but even more upset that this is
like graveyard scene number five in
these movies gee why doesn't check out
how much rent is there it's practically
a second home and everybody is wondering
well spider-man ever come back wheel
through the magic of castaway editing
yes they just say five months go by he's
suddenly feeling better daddy's back to
kicking ass and telling jokes almost
like the Hulk Wednesday see thing never
happened but at least she's spending
that time talking to Harry and trying to
figure out how his best friend became a
killer but no time for that okay well at
least she's spending the time trying to
find Uncle Ben's killer from the last
family no time for that either
well they got both of those are quite a
bear what the hell can be more important
oh yeah finding the land oh I'm in the
movie yes you are the end so the amazing
spider-man 2 with a lot of fun despite
the fact that throws everything at you
but the kitchen sink you think the more
you think about wives in their kitchen
sink man I gladly take on the role as
kitchen sink man I look like something
that would clog up your faucet and stop
everything like all these plus signs did
I remember movie this is jittery boom
see you got change fuck about have a
diarrhea - my leg come on I'll use it to
send the Rhino to wine country with the
Sandman if somehow the Rhino will be
snubbed for an Oscar